thanks to deep sentinel for keeping
legal eagles safe and sound
texas files an insane lawsuit that goes
straight to the supreme court that
doesn't seek a recount it doesn't seek
to add votes that were discarded
but it seeks to invalidate the entire
election for almost every swing state
our request is we want to be heard the
only place we can go is the u.s supreme
court
and so we're pleading with the u.s
supreme court
hey it's devin from the future again uh
so funny story about an hour after i
finished recording this video for the
first time
the supreme court issued a summary
dismissal of the texas lawsuit
so this lawsuit is now dead but there's
so much that's interesting about the
texas lawsuit that
even though we now know the actual
result which is that this case is dead
it's still worth going over what was
trying to be accomplished in this
particular lawsuit so
stick around until the end of this video
where devin from the further future will
come back
and actually explain the court's
dismissal of this lawsuit a lot of
people are calling this a
seven to two dismissal it's actually not
for reasons that i will explain
but let's actually dig into the analysis
of this particular lawsuit with devin
from the past and i'll come back in the
future
to talk about the dismissal that
happened about an hour ago
yeah it all makes sense in a timely why
me jeremy bear me sort of way
hey legals it's time to think like a
politician because
you don't need to think like a lawyer to
understand that the texas lawsuit is
nonsense and it's a political stunt
rather than a legal strategy
texas filed a lawsuit in the supreme
court asking the court to overturn the
presidential results in georgia michigan
pennsylvania and wisconsin
the lawsuit seeks an injunction
preventing the electoral college from
voting on december 14th
the texas case was filed by its attorney
general ken paxton
who has some legal woes of his own that
we'll come back to later on
why yes that is a mugshot of the texas
attorney general
17 other states filed an amicus brief in
support of texas
this doesn't technically mean that
they've joined the lawsuit think of it
as an aggrieved trump state just yelling
me too it's a friend of the court brief
you're adding your authority and your
approval for the
lawsuit but it actually doesn't mean
that you have joined the lawsuit it will
have no impact on the outcome of this
particular lawsuit
now trump won the popular vote in texas
and the other 17 states that have joined
in this lawsuit
the four states they are attacking gave
the popular vote to joe biden more
specifically urban voters in those four
states selected biden at a much higher
rate than
now president trump and tellingly the
lawsuit doesn't ask the court to
overturn any of the other races on these
ballots many of which went for
republicans
it's laser focused on stopping joe biden
from becoming president by
disenfranchising voters in urban areas
and their suburbs
22 states and washington dc have now
filed their own amicus briefs in
opposition to the texas suit
now before i delve into these claims
here's a quick reminder about how
american elections work because it's
crazy system
but it's our system and it's important
to understand this lawsuit
the constitution's election clause
article 1 section 4 empowers states to
determine
the time places and manner of
congressional elections subject of
course to congress's authority to make
or alter state regulations
state and local governments have the
authority to pass election laws
including rules about voter registration
voter protection fraud prevention
vote counting and determination of
election results now america does not
have
national elections as we are very
cognizant of
the 50 states run their individual
elections as they see fit and as long as
those rules don't violate the
constitution
the states can do what they want and
generally republicans have been in favor
of this
patchwork approach because it allows
them the flexibility in
certain states generally the red ones to
put in generally more restrictive voting
laws often claiming it's necessary to
prevent voter fraud
and conservatives once applauded this
design as an example of
federalism and states rights because it
gives states the right to run their own
affairs remember when
republicans used to care about states
rights the texas lawsuit wants the
supreme court to turn
against federalism and nationalize the
rules for voting effectively
you can argue that this would be a good
thing and that our system doesn't make
sense
i would probably agree with you but
changing it isn't something the supreme
court can
generally do especially after the
election has already occurred
and you'd have to change the
constitution to require uniformity in
voting laws it would require a
constitutional amendment of course both
congress and state governments are
constrained by the constitution as it
currently
exists but with that out of the way
let's turn to the texas lawsuit and
start at the beginning and ask
does this case satisfy the threshold
requirements for supreme court
jurisdiction
now i'll warn you ahead of time we're
going to get into the incredibly
sexy topic of supreme court jurisdiction
so if there are any
young children watching this video
please ask them to leave the room or
avert their attention because it's gonna
get a little out of hand
but that being said texas alleges that
the biden states made unconstitutional
decisions about how they decided to run
the 2020 election
but before we dig into the merits of
this claim texas has to prove that the
supreme court
can and should hear this particular case
because
it's very difficult to get into the
supreme court and as we've often talked
about on this channel
almost any time someone says that
they're going to take this all the way
to the supreme court it's total nonsense
because
there's a long long way you have to go
before you can get a case
to the supreme court but texas has
skipped all of that and they went
straight to the supreme court and it's
not as crazy as it first seems because
article 3 section 2 of the constitution
establishes the supreme court's
jurisdiction
the court has original jurisdiction over
lawsuits between two or more states
the court has appellate jurisdiction on
almost any other case that involves a
point of constitutional or federal law
but texas is invoking the court's
original jurisdiction which means that
this is a new case that can bypass all
of the other lower courts
but this doesn't mean that the court has
to hear the case
the state has to file a motion for leave
asking the court to hear the dispute and
that's what texas did
however texas went one step further by
applying for emergency injunctive relief
texas says that the court should
intervene quickly and stop the four
defendant states from relying on the
popular vote results and appointing
electors
in other words texas would like the
supreme court to tell those four states
they need to
cancel the biden votes and then they
just simply want the small favor that
the court will force the legislatures in
those four states to appoint electors
who will select trump
ignoring what the majority voters in
that state wanted and what state law
demands
you know no big deal now when the court
accepts
original jurisdiction cases with facts
disputes it usually appoints a special
master to gather evidence
and this process usually takes a long
time state disputes over water rights
for instance have lingered in the
supreme court for
20 years but president trump doesn't
have 20 years so
the paxton texas brief argues that the
supreme court should hurry up and decide
this with no additional briefing that's
why
texas argues that the issues in this
litigation are neither fact-bound nor
complex
but this does bring up another obvious
question if the issues are obvious and
non-complex why did texas wait until a
month after the election to file the
lawsuit
and why haven't any of the other
lawsuits succeeded now the supreme
court's original jurisdiction
can get complex but generally speaking
the supreme court has narrowly
interpreted its constitutional grant of
original jurisdiction
whether the supreme court has
jurisdiction is a threshold question
which means that
the court has to be satisfied it should
take this case up before getting to the
merits
and there are many threshold problems
with this lawsuit
the first of which is the question of
standing which is a topic that we've
covered many times in relation to
the election lawsuits the first problem
is that texas may not have standing to
bring the case
standing is the ability of a party to
demonstrate to the court that it has
enough connections to the alleged harm
that
it has the right to file a lawsuit
generally speaking to file a lawsuit
you have to be the party that was
actually harmed for example you can't go
into the court and say that
well my neighbor's house was robbed and
i want to file suit on their behalf
you don't get to do that you have to
actually personally have been harmed
and here the right party to challenge
election laws in other states would
probably be the
candidates and voters of that state it's
a little crazy for a state to say that
they were harmed by what happened
in another state's election but
president trump
and the other candidates and the voters
have already had the opportunity to
litigate their claims
in those states but generally speaking
they've lost
all of those cases texas argues that it
has standing because
what the other states do impacts who won
the presidential election
but if that's the case then other states
should start suing texas because they
disagree with the state's election rules
it would basically just destroy the
entire concept of standing
and as texas gop whip john thune
confirms
i just don't know why a state like texas
which never wants anybody telling them
what to do
now wants to tell a bunch of other
states how to run their elections
yeah it's kind of crazy and
ding ding ding ding from the future
that's exactly how the court came down
saying that texas has absolutely no
standing whatsoever to be filing this
lawsuit
in the first place got that right but
that takes us to the second problem
estoppel the second problem is that
these same claims have already been
adjudicated
in other courts there's a legal doctrine
called estoppel that prevents the
parties from litigating the same cause
of action or issues once they've already
been decided by other courts it's sort
of like
double jeopardy but for civil cases now
republicans have tried to get the
supreme court to hear the cases
the lower courts have dismissed but so
far the court has declined
and here texas is simply trying to do an
end run around those other cases
which they already lost which brings us
to the third problem which is the
doctrine of latches which
means a party is barred if it
unreasonably takes too long before
bringing a legal claim
and here texas complains about changes
to election laws in other states that
happened
months before the elections the alleged
issues texas complains about were also
obvious while the voters were still
being counted
and under federal law election disputes
are supposed to be resolved by six days
before the electoral college meets
a deadline known as the safe harbor
which was december 8th
the texas lawsuit wasn't filed until
december 7th day before
why didn't texas do it sooner and why
didn't texas
file before the election if it already
knew
what the problems were in the other
states and as one of the briefs make
clear
it's because they didn't know who was
going to win the election which is
the epitome of writing the quiet part
out loud i mean writing the quiet part
in the brief it's just crass
and unbelievable which takes us to the
fourth problem which is known as the
political question doctrine
to be the kind of matter that a court
can adjudicate the dispute needs to be a
legal one not
a political one and when the court
decides whether the issue is a political
one or a legal one
it looks to whether the problem is
within the purview of another branch of
government
in this case the constitution provides
that the congress is the ultimate judge
of the electoral college results
republicans are well aware of this
because they are already plotting a
floor
fight when congress meets to certify the
results
so that kind of seems like a political
question
which takes us to the fifth problem
which is the case is arguably moot
a dispute can become moot when the
controversy initially existed the time
the lawsuit was filed
and it's no longer live due to a change
in the law or status of the parties
involved
and 49 of 50 states have already
certified their election results
by the safe harbor day and the president
and his team
of kraken wranglers have already been
litigating these issues since
election day and they've lost basically
every single one of these cases they've
lost over 60 times
and arguably there's nothing left for
the supreme court to decide
you know what issue isn't moot is
hitting the notification belt i was
checking my stats and only 10 percent of
people have
enabled notifications it'd mean the
world to me if you would subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you'll
know when a video comes out
which takes us to the sixth problem
which is that the remedy that texas
wants to disenfranchise millions of
voters
after they've already voted is probably
grossly unconstitutional
texas wants the supreme court to extend
the electoral college deadline
the supreme court has never granted such
an extreme remedy in a voting case
it didn't even do this in bush versus
gore that case involved 537 votes in one
state while i strongly disagree with the
court's decision
i accept it and this is radically
different
considering what's at stake here but
texas thinks that the republican
legislators in the four defendant states
should be allowed to cancel all the
votes and just pick trump
in our system the people have a right to
cast votes for the president
the states in question don't like who
the voters selected so they want the
republican legislatures to pick instead
that's extraordinary and also incredibly
dangerous to democracy itself
but all right let me get down for my
soapbox and let's play along with the
lawsuit let's say that the supreme court
believes this suit satisfies
all of these threshold questions and
then it turns to the merits
well we get into a lot of the same
questions that we've already talked
about in terms of election lawsuits
texas alleges that the four defendant
states violated their own laws by
changing their election procedures in
2020.
the theory is that this violated the
equal protection clause by allowing
different sets of voters to be treated
differently
within their states even if this were a
valid equal protection claim it would
not overturn the electoral college
results because
the votes have already been cast the
remedy would not be to disallow millions
of ballots that were cast by voters who
did nothing wrong
all these voters did was follow the
rules now texas and 17 other states
want those votes cancelled but how would
that be equitable or constitutional
and we already talked about how bogus
these equal protection claims are in the
context of the kelly versus pennsylvania
suit
in a prior election video but
disenfranchising one set of voters would
present its own equal protection
problems especially since the president
is obsessed with what happened
in urban areas which voted
overwhelmingly
for future president biden texas is
arguing that
those votes don't matter and a.g paxton
is already on very thin ice here because
he's already raised all of these fake
election fraud claims in the lower
courts which have already been dismissed
texas claims that there are voting
irregularities that would be consistent
with the unconstitutional relaxation of
ballot integrity protections in those
states
election laws and there's a long list of
complaints that we've already heard
about and
generally which has already been
adjudicated in other places allegedly
missing usb drives ballots
being delivered in food trucks alleged
statistical disparities poll workers
doing something nefarious when
other poll watchers weren't looking
these are allegations that have already
been addressed in many different
jurisdictions
almost always the court finds them to be
completely bogus and made up
and even if all of those allegations
were true which time and time again it's
been proved that they aren't
why would texas have any kind of
standing whatsoever to make a claim
about those allegations it doesn't make
any sense
and that brings us to the electors
clause texas also claims that it's
unconstitutional for a state legislature
to delegate their power to make election
laws to
state courts or even to the governor
texas claims that by quote taking or
allowing
non-legislative actions to change the
election results that would govern the
appointment of presidential electors
the defendant states have violated the
elector's clause the equal protection
clause and the due process clause
and ironically it turns out that texas
is guilty of doing
the very thing that it complains about
texas governor greg abbott extended the
early voting period
is texas suing itself spoiled alert it
is not
but texas is supported in these claims
by 17 states who filed a friend of the
court brief in amicus brief
these states argue that it was
unconstitutional for pennsylvania judges
to let absentee ballots be
counted if they were postmarked by
election day but arrived afterward
like texas these states are utterly
blind to their own hypocrisy
kansas and mississippi also count
mail-in ballots if they arrive late
so are they calling out their own laws
as unconstitutional as well
it doesn't really seem like it but again
the fact that states have different laws
about voting
doesn't violate the elections clause the
constitution was
set up that way the elections clause
gives states the right to decide
the way votes are cast and counted it
doesn't give texas or any other state a
right to veto
okay but enough about the merits or lack
thereof of this particular lawsuit
let's talk about some of the procedural
hijinks first there is president trump's
motion to intervene
president trump filed a motion to
intervene in this lawsuit remember this
was brought by
the texas attorney general here the
president for some reason is being
represented by john eastman a lawyer who
is most famous for writing an article
suggesting that
as an american-born child of immigrants
kamala harris wasn't really
an american citizen it sort of goes
downhill from there
but what is president trump actually
arguing well quote
despite the chaos of the election night
and the days which followed the media
has consistently proclaimed that no
widespread voter fraud has been proven
but this observation misses the point
the constitutional issue is not whether
voters committed fraud but whether state
officials violated the law
by systematically loosening the measure
for ballot integrity so that fraud
becomes
undetectable they're arguing that the
fraud is so good that it can't be
detected therefore
president trump wins i don't need to
tell you that this
is pure nonsense that contradicts what
the trump lawyers have been saying for
over a month that poll watchers saw the
stuff that was fraud
and that the dominion voting machines
created fraud and that the democrats
injected fake ballots into the final
counts
every lawsuit filed by the kraken says
that she
figured out the entire scheme but now
eastman argues that it is not necessary
for the plaintiffs and interventions to
prove that fraud occurred it is only
necessary to demonstrate that the
elections
in the defendant states materially
deviated from the manner of choosing
electors established by their respective
state legislatures
now i will point out parenthetically
that perhaps the biggest irony of this
motion to intervene where the president
says that
he would like to be a party in this
lawsuit actually
may prevent the court from actually
addressing the lawsuit because remember
we talked about original jurisdiction
and the fact that
trump is arguing he has standing to be
in this lawsuit
sort of cast doubt on the idea that this
is a lawsuit between one state and the
other states
it shows that this case can and should
have been litigated
in the various states where the harm
allegedly occurred
and doesn't need original jurisdiction
before the supreme court it's the
ultimate irony that
by blustering his way into this suit he
may actually be making it
jurisdictionally impossible for the
supreme court to
actually adjudicate it now you might be
saying devin
are these states really suing because
they don't like the outcome
well yes it seems that's exactly what
they're saying
this lawsuit is very possibly nothing
but bad faith now
keep in mind that pennsylvania has been
fighting the same issues since before
the election and the courts keep ruling
in the state's favor
even when the judges are trump
appointees but
in this particular case and i usually
don't engage in this kind of speculation
it's possible that the attorney general
for texas might have brought the suit
for reasons unrelated to the election
itself but
actually to try and curry favor with the
president to get
a presidential pardon as ridiculous as
that sounds
that seems to be the most likely reason
for filing this suit
texas attorney general paxton has been
under indictment since 2015 on
securities fraud charges relating to
activities that happened
before he was elected these generally
are state charges and
just for the hell of it here's ken
paxton stealing a thousand dollar pen
from the same courthouse where he was
indicted
this is ken paxton the indicted texas
attorney general
rummaging through the metal detector
trays and stealing that one thousand
dollar pen
and this is ken paxton the indicted
texas attorney general
walking away with a stolen pen but then
earlier this year he was accused of
committing crimes while
in office this time the call came from
inside the house
his own aides contacted federal law
enforcement authorities and asked them
to investigate allegations of improper
influence abusive office
bribery and other potential crimes
several lawyers
resigned and other personnel say that
they're being retaliated against for
reporting paxton's criminality
the texas solicitor general who would
normally join a filing like this
in the texas versus pennsylvania lawsuit
did not sign
any of these pleadings which indicates
that he doesn't want to be associated
with this lawsuit
he'd probably like to avoid being swept
up in paxton's issues himself
now why is all of this relevant well ken
paxton
could actually use a presidential pardon
he hasn't been charged with a federal
crime yet but just this week the fbi
subpoenaed his office indicating that an
investigation is ongoing
paxton chatted on the phone with
president trump and then he filed this
lawsuit
but don't take my word for it even
republican senator ben sasse sees
this as a pardon grab now in passing
i'll mention a couple of the other
amicus briefs that were filed these are
not binding
they're not parties to the suit but it's
interesting that they filed these with
the court they
want their opinions to be known and
montana governor steve bullock filed his
own
amicus brief to make it clear that
neither texas nor trump
sought to throw out the selection of
presidential electors in states that
made the same legal changes to voting
rules as the defendant states
stating quote texas chose not to include
the state of montana where president
trump and other republicans were
successful in a mail-ballot election
conducted to reduce the impact of covid
underscoring of course that
this action is less about election
integrity than it is about attempting to
overturn the will of the electorate
but if texas is successful in its suit
it would destabilize the results of
elections in montana and any other state
that took valid state law actions
to minimize the impact of the virus on
voting including states that delivered
victories to republican candidates using
mail ballots
and of course there were the insane
ramblings of the amicus brief on behalf
of the state of new california and
new nevada i was born and raised in old
california so i was actually
quite surprised to learn of the 51st and
52nd state of new california and new
nevada
not surprisingly this legal brief is
sovereign citizen level
absolute garbage nonsense uh we're all
dumber for having
read it and may god have mercy on their
soul for
actually filing this nonsense amicus
brief
may god have mercy on your soul hey
it's devin from the future again and as
i promised at the beginning of this
video
we now have the known conclusion to this
particular lawsuit which is that
the supreme court has summarily
dismissed the suit
and it did so in two very terse
paragraphs the first stating that
the state of texas's motion for leave to
file a bill of complaint is denied for
lack of standing under article 3 of the
constitution
article 3 of the constitution is the one
that just says what jurisdiction
the courts actually have it creates the
federal courts in the united states
and then it says texas has not
demonstrated a judicially cognizable
interest in the manner in which another
state conducts its elections
all other pending motions are dismissed
as moot so
there you have it texas doesn't have any
cognizable injury it doesn't have
standing to argue that what other states
do
is bad and that it can reverse the
results from different states
if it has an issue with the way that
things were run in its own state or if
there are people who are
injured in those states then they can
file suit and they can sue
those particular states but the state of
texas has no interest
in being able to file a lawsuit
no interest in the legal sense obviously
we have an ag here who wants to overturn
the results
but in a legal sense they don't have an
interest to be able to file a lawsuit
it's like
trying to make a lawsuit over something
that happened to your neighbor
when it didn't affect you in any way or
shape or form
and then so a lot of people get the
second paragraph of this dismissal wrong
which there are two justices that say
that they would have
heard the case specifically statement of
justice alito with whom justice thomas
joins
in my view we do not have discretion to
deny the filing of a bill of complaint
in a case that falls within our original
jurisdiction
see arizona versus california citation i
would therefore grant the motion to file
the bill of complaints but would not
grant other relief and i express
no view on any other issue really all
that's saying
is that there are two justices on the
supreme court that say that
if a claimant one of the states that has
a claim
under original jurisdiction the court
has to hear it and
there are differing opinions on that
some most of the justices on the supreme
court say that it's discretionary
whether the supreme court will take up
the case all these two people are saying
justice alito and justice thomas are
saying is that
if there is a case that sounds in the
court's original jurisdiction
the supreme court of the united states
must hear it no exceptions whatsoever
but
almost certainly they wouldn't have
granted the lawsuit they wouldn't have
granted the relief they still would have
kicked out the case
they're just saying that they would have
heard the case not summarily dismissed
it
and here's the thing about this
particular lawsuit it was always going
to fail it was
nonsense whether the supreme court
actually heard it or not under original
jurisdiction or just bounced it like
they did
it was always going to fail and i'm torn
on this because
you're allowed to file lawsuits even
meritless ones though
there are mechanisms for punishing
people that file meritless lawsuits
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
we shouldn't judge the people that filed
lawsuits that strike at the very heart
of our democracy if it had been
successful
so to ken paxton and the 17 other states
that joined in this case
and the over 100 gop senators that
supported this lawsuit
it's their right to do so but that
doesn't mean we can't judge them
and judge them harshly for it but here's
the thing
texas attorney general ken paxton is
still on the loose and he's coming for
your votes and he's coming for your
thousand dollar pens
so you'd better get a great security
system to stop him and deep sentinel is
just that
i used to live in a house with a
traditional security system with one of
those stupid keypad where the alarm
would go off and
if you didn't enter your code in in time
and i actually got fined hundreds of
dollars when the police were called out
on a
false alarm after false alarm but deep
sentinel is different
deep sentinel is the only security
system that actually monitors your
property in real time and will
intervene before something bad happens
when the camera detects a visitor the
guards log into your system assess the
situation and then
the loud two-way speaker lets a guard
intervene and stop crime before it
happens they can
ask the visitor questions or tell them
that the police are on the way it's
absolute genius and of course i can
check on all of the status
as it's happening with my cell phone and
because it's real humans
they're virtually no false alarms
because they're actually looking at
what's happening on the scene and of
course
deep sentinel is wi-fi and app enabled
so i can pull out my phone and check out
my front porch or backyard with one
click
anywhere in the world and i can turn on
the two-way radio myself and talk to a
delivery person
or the guests when they arrive and the
system automatically tells me when i get
packages delivered
so if you'd like to try deep sentinel
legal eagles will get a special
20 off if you go to deep sentinel dot
com slash legal eagle or use the promo
code legaleagle20 at checkout
but this is a special deal it's the best
deal they have ever offered and it will
expire in a few days so be sure to get
20
off by going to deepsentinel.com
legaleagle or using the link in the
description plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis will this be the last election
lawsuit i have to cover
probably not which is why you should
check out this playlist with all of my
other real law reviews talking about the
election issues and everything that's
going on with the presidential
transition
so click on this playlist and i'll see
you in court